it's not my place or donald trump's
place to declare
who's won this election that's the
decision of the american people
but i'm optimistic about this outcome
this is a fraud
on the american public this is an
embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
joe biden and donald trump speak out as
election night leaves the
presidential results up in the air
we knew this was gonna go wrong but who
knew we're gonna go
into maybe tomorrow morning maybe even
longer
but look we feel good about where we are
we really do
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm here to tell you tonight we believe
we're on track to win this election
democratic presidential candidate biden
gave a short speech to a crowd of
supporters at a drive-in gathering
outside the chase center in wilmington
delaware where he said he felt confident
about winning arizona michigan wisconsin
and
pennsylvania it ain't over until every
vote is counted
every ballot is counted but i'm
optimistic about this outcome
and i want to thank every one of you who
came out
and voted in this election keep the
faith guys we're going to win this
shortly after biden spoke president
donald trump
addressed the nation from the white
house and while the outcome of the
election remained
unclear he claimed victories in states
where the results had not yet been
decided
states like georgia and pennsylvania
where millions of ballots had yet to be
counted
it's also clear that we have won georgia
we're up by 2.5
or 117 000 votes with
only 7 left they're never going to catch
us they can't catch us
but most importantly we're winning
pennsylvania by a tremendous amount
trump also alleged this election was
ripe with voter fraud and he claimed he
planned to take it to the supreme court
this is a major fraud in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list okay
it's it's a very sad it's a very sad
moment to me this is a very sad moment
and
we will win this and as far as i'm
concerned we already have one